there's your boy dave principal oh david
was pretty cool too
i'd rather have one eye and be dan
crunch out and you have two eyes
are they related who uh yeah who is dave
christopher he looks like he's a
motivational speaker which i'm already
having a problem with yeah
already i already have an issue with
yeah you don't [ __ ] with those
motivations
i'll tell you something whenever they
they do this
book the results yeah oh yeah yeah
yeah brian read it clearly yeah yeah
what did you do oh you haven't done
anything but you
oh here you go you have a business of
being a motivational author speaker and
online trainer
building productive leaders you're not a
builder when he's cooking diagnosed with
adhd who's not dude wow man
i just we're just hanging on they've got
sharks
you [ __ ] hate those i i live in l.a
so what i've seen
time and again is what happens is people
hustle they come to be actors now things
don't work out so it's a tough gig so
what happens is
you have a you have what's called a
mental breakdown
no i'm not trying to be a dick so when
you have a mental breakdown you go and
buy a suit
so when you look at you turn on the
youtube camera look at me on your 40
and and you go it's actually not going
to work out
i'm not going to be emailing you the
whole dream board my goal sheet ain't
going to work out now
you got a choice you can either die you
can either just
jump right the [ __ ] out the window move
to new mexico or you
can say i got to learn how to get
through this
yeah i'm going to read some books on how
to do this and get through it
and what you do is you convince yourself
that it's going to be all right and then
you become
an influence a life yeah i'm always
curious i'm like who
like like what gave them that now
michael jordan released five steps i'm
reading
i'm reading the book but there's a lot
of these people that slap dick with all
that botox and a bad suits like this is
my five steps
to successful you know yeah i mean it's
i don't know who that guy's i don't want
to be mean but there are no you're not
you don't mean me but like i i give you
they're all calling artists they're all
they're all just trying to shift the
system and like trying to make it but
it gives you it gives you an icky
feeling i just don't think you ever
accomplish anything or get actually what
you want done
with five easy steps with a saying
with an inspirational quote i don't
believe
put your ideas on a perhaps list to
promote creative thinking in a
manageable way
the more simple the email the higher
chance of getting a response goals
without a plan are just wishes the more
simple the email the higher chance of
getting a response oh my god thank god
dude i'm glad i read this want to show
someone you care
give them your attention yeah i hate
these
i hate these [ __ ] rules i this is
what you do
it's very basic well yeah this is how
you sell it but it's also like
obviously yeah that's what i'm saying
click the other one click on the go up
click on the one that goes there if you
care give them attention how many likes
does that have
if you can it was higher no no no no no
right below someone you care gives me
your attention
i got it yep 28 likes that's what you
get
and that was february 3rd and just have
you ever had someone stare at their
phone
tapping away on the screen while
listening to you how did that make you
feel now you're now for a tougher
question how many times have you been
the one
switch task on a person who's talking to
you i get it i literally wrote the book
on this
but i still do it too sometimes give
people your full attention
all right people deserve our full
attention no they don't
most of the time
this is the thing i i don't know
honestly like i don't know if there are
any shortcuts
like i i think it takes a really long
time
to get good at something like i i don't
care who your agent is i don't care who
the
you're you're either like to be a really
good stand-up comic
that the challenge never goes away oh
it's a really good boxer to be a really
good piano player i mean i'll see you in
10 years
and you better be practicing all the
time yeah you know
there yeah there's there's no shortcuts
no shortcuts well
dave crenshaw makes a difference dave
this is a five-step program for 49.99 a
month
i think i think of it as a high-tech
procrastination so i watched tony
robbins
like uh knows he's the real deal though
he's the real deal but okay he's big
he's like the big the biggest but when
he has those the most when he has those
seminars i've watched and i'm not your
guru it's a really good documentary but
what i saw was a bunch of dudes who were
they're building themselves up and we
can do this and you change your mindset
and it's positive affirmation
thinking to me that's high-tech
procrastination i don't give a [ __ ]
about
believing in myself i never believe in
myself you know what makes me believe
myself when i get good at something then
i can believe myself
yeah just do the [ __ ] work learn how
to do something and you'll get closer
are you picturing a motivational book
now because yeah
now i'm annoyed yeah yeah the book says
you know my book says yeah one page
ready it should
be forever it just takes forever takes
forever yeah
it takes forever and and practice every
day and you might still not make it
yeah and when you get there it won't
feel like you're there
it's about i i've said this i've said
this before my my success feels like
like when i
at one point two tv shows [ __ ] big
podcast
and somebody said well but it was like
somebody was like you got so successful
what's your what's your secret
do you
i've been doing this for 26 years like
26 years it's so long like and i said
it's the equivalent of throwing a rock
at a sparrow every time it flies by my
[ __ ] doorway
if i did that for 25 years every day all
day i'd hit some sparrows i'd get some
sparrows knock him out of the [ __ ]
sky
that's that's doesn't mean i'm a good
rock thrower just means i threw the
[ __ ]
rocks at every sparrow that came by so
it's just that i don't know
you throwing a [ __ ] [ __ ] on the wall
some of it's gonna stick
yeah you get seven yeses in in one
million those
all right it's not even that it's just
just but that tony robbins stuff works
for people more power to you man
you know what
you know the one thing i listen to
everything he did because i was writing
a tv show on a self-help guru
okay okay and i wanted to make fun of
him and i got sucked in do you know the
one thing i got from his thing that i
can remember that i still think about
tony robbins yeah he said he said one is
he's very big on setting goals right
specific goals writing him down
but he said the main thing i heard was
he said change
your primary question i was like what
the [ __ ] that mean he goes
most people have a question in their
mind that's not helpful it's a question
like am i good enough
am i lovable will i make it it's an
awesome question right i'm out but he
said
reprogram your brain to ask a better
question so what do i have to do today
to get closer to my goal
or something like that or who what do i
want what would i ask for if i knew i
couldn't fail so he has these questions
that that makes sense
yeah they got you you're asking yourself
a question not a [ __ ] negative
question that doesn't have a good answer
to it
yeah so change the primary question like
how how do i get into this
how do i get in at this comedy club
which is not a little whatever it is
like like but that's all i remember but
sometimes
i think in a way my default was always
kind of like
it's not that hard to see what you want
right like if you start something like
when you join the ufc you're like i want
to be a champion that's not that
complicated you just
you figure out who you have to train
with pretty complicated no it's hard
i'm not saying i'm saying setting a goal
is not complicated like you said
but then you go well what do i have to
do that's those people's problems aren't
their goals they they don't know what
they want they don't know yeah
they're professional athletes that's not
no professional athlete has a issue
going i don't know what i want
yeah that's why you turn to tony robbins
you don't know what you want you don't
if you did you won't be buying his books
you'd be doing here
hey some people are probably successful
they can't if it helps more power too
long you'll [ __ ] get into satanism
i think that's what motivates you more
power to you man i think getting good at
anything
is a good way to get to the next thing
like learning somehow this turned into
motivation
which drives me absolutely bonkers i
know it's driving me
are you doing it and i'm like hey look
it's like mine is just right i hate this
[ __ ] that mine's like it's one step at a
and people ask me how did you do it and
i'm like you just gotta
start i'm like oh my god now you're
doing what [ __ ] dave peterson's doing
i am a little bit happy so it's
exhausting i'm a little better than you
about the same come on dude
did you see his followers hold on ready
change ready ready
change the primary question in your
brain and it takes forever
go for free change the question
write that down write that down change
the question
you don't like you don't like
inspirational quotes oh my gosh just go
man
let's go just do it go
i like makeup i'm sorry i was thinking
about it make up those
pick up your own inspiration
let me hear you make up your own
inspirational quote you have five
seconds oh [ __ ] come on you have to
do it one you [ __ ] do it
do it yeah that's it yeah that's not
nike's thing dude
but that's what i said [ __ ] do it
just [ __ ] do
it if you ask me if you have to ask me
you're probably not gonna make it oh
yeah